is it kind of an amazing thing I know
you've probably been asked this a
million times but to be a part of
something so monumental like so
important in pop culture like everyone
rushed on Thursday nights to watch that
show like we literally everyone I know
watched it like that's it's funny now I
mean if it felt really huge but the way
things are now with like social media
and streaming and your ability to binge
watch something that was back before
they get VCRs back then yeah nobody knew
how to do wait yeah but nobody could
figure out how to tape a show I do right
there you can press record but like to
the program and you've got the news yeah
but now it's a its it feels somehow just
as relevant now is it as it did back
then yeah it's it's funny because we're
all so much older now you know what I
mean then you mean it's on TV you think
God look at Liz so young and then come
on baby I feel like that was my career
as well um could you leave the house
though back in the height of height of
it all cuz I remember we were actually
both at the same award track can't
remember what it was but it was during
American Idol and y'all were a couple of
y'all were there and everybody was
swarming around y'all and so I was like
oh my god that's gotta be rough yeah
well you know there's some weird things
that happened you know back back then I
remember one time so it was during the
week I was an ass it was just like
during the afternoon I'd be flipping
channels I was watching the news and for
some reason they had like a split screen
on the TV six quadrants wouldn't be
quadrants but six equal and each was a
live shot of each one of our houses like
a helicopter show they've casted friends
houses and I was like okay what what is
this what's going on here and I'm
watching it was like a not there was no
information and no news really just
showing the houses and we're looking
close at my house and thinking I need a
new roof so the helicopter flies away I
get the ladder out
well man with the plan is back so how is
this show how do you love the chemistry
of this cast this this shows fun you
know um I fit I had finished doing
episodes for Showtime which was really
fun and then like I'd never played a guy
that was in a relationship or a dad and
you know now I have a daughter and yeah
I figured I'm old now must be time to
play again yeah so it's just you know
it's not a high concept show it's just
about this family yeah and when you
that's what's so relatable about it
there's so many things that happen just
in a regular family's life that it's
just been really really fun and Stacy
Keach plays my dad he's awesome Kevin
Nealon plays my brother he's really hard
to work with because he's so funny I
just hadn't up laughs a long time in
Eliza Schneider plays my wife and we
have a really great cast so we're into
season four now and then I think it's
our best best season yet I love I love
that it's so available though I have
totally heard our 18 year old daughter
and my husband just like completely
arguing about her shorts and how they
were basically a bathing suit bottom
yeah it's always like that whole slow
striptease hilarious yeah my daughter's
16 now we have the same kind of family
where's the rest of your shirt yeah why
are you we have money you can afford a
whole shirt yeah and then you start to
think that what you did when you're
younger and then you just get frightened
but yeah I didn't shirts like that one I
know I'm so nervous for our girls
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going